because a lot of people don't want to
listen to pouchy don't want to wear the
masks forever and don't want to
take the 17th booster shot and done even
now i fly on airlines constantly i'm
just i've been every few days i've been
on a flight for the past two months
especially i was on one i was on two
flights yesterday actually to to and
from los angeles and i'm noticing they
don't
they don't really enforce the mask thing
anymore and i'm not sure if it's because
the airlines don't want to do it or i
think it's just because people aren't
going to do it and so
the ruling class
only has so much power if we all just
said no they would be helpless
right and so they do have to calibrate
their
rule
to what we're willing to tolerate
right that is that is why dr fatty
initially said i i don't know if you can
have christmas in thanksgiving and then
there was a big push back and he said oh
never mind never mind i never said that
what do you know you can have it just
get 17 more boosters get this get you
know and it's it's a bit of a
negotiation so because people are sick
of this nonsense the ruling class is
pulling out all the steps the
entertainment the media saturday night
live
they just they ran i i guess what's
supposed to be a comedy sketch
about a flap between big bird and ted
cruz
the the muppets and sesame street
insisting that everyone take a bunch of
vaccines ted cruz said make your own
medical decisions and don't listen to a
puppet bird and
and joe rogan too was in this just take
a listen
tell me if you can identify the comedy
well that's right
i used the whole sphere factor and now
doctors fear me
can you help me joe oh sure thing big
bird you see i said carlos mencia down i
could take coven
here's some zinc
an ayahuasca
and some horse medicine
why would a bird take horse medicine i'm
a human and i took horse medicine
and i'm speaking of things that uh are
horse-like
uh today's two sponsors are the letters
s and d as in i can s my own d
what
what was the joke
you were there was some laughing i mean
i wonder if it was laugh track or if it
was the actual studio audience or maybe
some combination but even with that even
with a studio audience and potentially a
laugh track
a bunch of those lines didn't even land
they didn't i don't even know what the
joke was
was the joke that
joe rogan took some kooky witch doctor
medicine for kovid that wouldn't work
joe rogan recovered from the coronavirus
in like five hours
is that the joke is that he took horse
medicine he didn't take horse medicine
though
is the joke that uh
joe rogan is some fringe lunatic but
dr fauci or you know dr fauci is now uh
viceroy and vickers you know and through
big bird and and other representatives
of the
ruling class that they are somehow
serious and respected and popular i
don't think they are i think joe rogan
is one of the most popular communicators
and broadcasters in the world
and dr fauci is the butt of everyone's
jokes
is is the is the joke that
the people who are questioning the
regime and questioning joe biden for
instance are fringe and weird and
radical and biden is really popular no
biden's approval rating is about as low
as it gets
what is it 37 38
what's the joke hunter douglas can help
you with their incredible window shade
designs gorgeous fabrics and control
systems that are so advanced they can be
scheduled to automatically adjust to
their optimal position throughout the
day
maybe it's the way the shades diffuse
harsh sunlight to cast a beautiful glow
across the room maybe it's being able to
enjoy the view outside the window while
protecting your privacy inside or maybe
it's just that goldilocks moment when
you walk into a room and everything
about it looks and feels just right i
find this especially as a conservative
myself i think aesthetics really matter
i think being in beautiful places really
matters especially with light it was one
of the main things i was focused on when
i was looking to get my house here in
tennessee
your shades can be set with hunter
douglas's power view technology they can
be set to automatically reposition for
the perfect balance of light privacy and
insulation go to hunterdouglas.com
knowles today take advantage of the
season of style rebate savings event
hunterdouglas.com knowles for limited
savings offer expires december 6th 2021.
the joke would
be like what what comedy used to do is
speak truth to power right what comedy
used to do is juxtapose incongruous
things
and
and it would be funny and you would
laugh at that which is ridiculous but in
in this case what is ridiculous is not
the fringe clown it's not it's not the
joe rogan what's ridiculous is the
ruling class
and saturday night live far from being a
critic of the ruling class is part of it
and it's a it's an extension of it and
it's part of the propaganda outlet and
so it's just not
funny it's just not funny and snl has
been hit or miss for an extremely long
time
really hasn't been funny since norma
mcdonald left the show but it's had its
moments this is a real low point and
they're not going to figure it out
until
they break away from the ruling class
but unfortunately it's the kind of the
ruling class that's propping up these
old desiccated establishment
institutions like the establishment
media and like even saturday night live
you you you hold on hold on
thank you for stopping by i'm glad you
watched that clip if you wouldn't mind
ring that bell subscribe you will get
notifications and if our overlords on
the big tech platforms don't give you
notifications i would strongly recommend
you head on over to apple podcasts
spotify stitcher google play wherever
you get your audio podcast subscribe to
the michael knowles show maybe leave a
five star review if you want to make me
feel good
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]